[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down the ending of uncut
gems the film closes with a lot of
things up in the air and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down what
we took from the final few scenes and
the overall themes behind the movie
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch it yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into our breakdown
of uncut gems
after a brief prologue that introduces
us to the rare and mystifying opal
pretty much becomes the MacGuffin of the
movie we meet Howard Ratner a gambling
addict that runs a jewelry store in New
York's Taemin district the first time we
come across the character is a rather
intimate moment during a colonoscopy in
which if polyps is found though whirring
at first it is revealed to be benign and
this sort of closeness to what could be
death and then the revelation that
everything will be okay is something
that's mirrored throughout the movie
uncut gems is intentionally filmed
edited and presented in a way that will
cause anxiety and predominantly we
follow Howard as he struggles to pay off
a $100,000 debt that he owes to his
brother-in-law Arno we're just going to
be giving a brief parte overview of
everything before we get into our
analysis on the film so we can properly
set things up in context that we're
discussing later on I'll try and keep it
as simple as possible and just cover the
main points but if you haven't seen the
film yet then I highly recommend that
you check it out anyway Howard lives
with his girlfriend Julia and the
character has a very estranged
relationship with his wife neither he
nor Dinah his ex have informed their
children that they're pretty much about
to get divorced and this is very much
about keeping up appearances which is
also exemplified in his brother-in-law
know who Howard is in debt to Howard
obtains
ople and wishes to listed at auction for
an estimated price of 1 million dollars
which he sure that he can get after
showing it to basketball player kevin
garnett the real-life figure becomes
obsessed with it and borrows it for good
luck in a game that night he pawns gone
it's ring which he takes his colour a
roll and places a bet on Garnett who
plays incredibly well though Howard wins
it is revealed that the bet was stopped
by oh no who were with his bodyguards
strip him naked and lock him in the
trunk of his car with help from his wife
diner howard is able to get out Howard
has trouble getting the upper back from
Garnett and he frantically chases after
it through the majority of the movie
everything sort of comes to a head when
he calls his employee Damini to try and
get it back for him and they agree to
meet at a party hosted by the weekend
here he finds out that gone it still has
the stone and he discovers Julia in the
bathroom with the singer they break up
and how it goes crawling back to his
wife who flat out refuses his advances
eventually gone it returns the opal and
offers to purchase it outright for a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars but Howard refuses this and
pushes it to auction unfortunately when
he gets there he realizes that the opals
value has been lowered and thus he
convinces his father and all too she'll
bid against garnet in order to drive up
the price Howard gets too greedy and
wins it and outside he's assaulted by
Ono and his thugs once more as a broken
man he rebuilt his relationship with
Julia we discover that garnet still
wishes to purchase the gem Arnaud
arrives at the store just as this is
happening and it looks like the
character could finally be out of debt
however Howard decides to bet all of the
money from garnet on the player that
night and he sends to you Lee arrived
places for him whilst he holds up Arnaud
and his gang in the shop after locking
them between security doors they're
forced to sit and watch the game play
out a miracle happens and Howard's
insane Beck comes off winning the
character 1.2 million dollars it looks
like we're gonna get a happy ending
but when Howard frees the thugs one of
them shoots him and then they kill our
know who tries to escape worried for him
dinah calls the police to check out
what's happening and they begin to
descend on the location the two enforces
then raid the store stealing everything
and we zoom in on how it's cheek which
then trans
forms into the inside of the mystical
stone before becoming the universe it's
a really trippy way to end the film but
there's actually a lot to take from it
now the first big question I've seen is
what happened to the money
well now julia has it the thugs will be
arrested and she will likely be able to
do what she wants with it however that
doesn't mean that there will be happy
ending and personally I think she may
even travel a similar path to the one
that we see Howard on in the film uncut
gems is very much about greed and how a
short-sighted view of things can
ultimately lead to your own downfall
Howard had several opportunities to pay
off the debt but instead he kept
gambling trying to win bigger and bigger
with no real perception of things around
him this is reflected in several
characters throughout the film and the
only one who doesn't seem transfixed by
the short-term is Dinah we know this
because she turns down Howard's advances
to repair their relationship because
she's been through this before and
already knows the outcome Howard on the
other hand repeats the cyclical behavior
that will offer short-term rewards but
not ones in the long term this is
murdered in the thugs who loot the store
and Julia which I'll get into in just a
bit okay
so as the film ends the thugs are
trapped in the store and that is
blatantly obvious we see throughout the
film
even when experienced people want to use
the security doors they have a lot of
difficulty with it the trappings of
their Sulli - one of the most
nail-biting moments in the movie I think
this is purely put in place to serve the
fact that the thugs are trapped there
and will be unable to escape in time for
the police that are closing in on the
position however they don't really seem
to care and are happy just living the
store for jewelry that we've seen
throughout the film isn't worth what its
value does they are purely focused on
the short term rather than the long term
the here and now the possession of these
objects rather than the lifetime in
prison that awaits them if they don't up
and leave immediately like come on just
just run please run Julia also follows a
similar sort of view and this highlights
to me how the money will be wasted by
the character this is exemplified by her
cheating on Howard with the weakened
early
in the film she had a great relationship
with the character and a stable job due
to him however she was more bothered
about a short-term thing in a nightclub
bathroom with a celebrity rather than
what it would do to her home employment
once more she's fixed purely on what's
in front of her rather than the bigger
picture
due to the weakened status he's sort of
an Opel for Julia and she's willing to
throw it all away just for him now it
does work out for an away but only
because Howard is too transfixed on the
short term and he takes her back
Howard lives in a constant cycle of
toxicity and thus she is able to go back
to him however not everyone is like that
and in the big wide world by itself I
believe she will end up losing the money
because of how she operates julia has
just won a huge sum of cash through
gambling and no doubt she would try this
again I mean who wouldn't I don't gamble
but if I'd won that kind of money from
gambling I probably put it all on black
with something stupid as for the ending
itself the topsy-turvy trip actually
means a lot and to me is a symbolism for
death and the great beyond uncut gems is
completely crazy whether it's the
characters constantly shouting over one
another things not working out how
they're supposed to or Howard placing
stupid bet or one after the other it
reflects our lives in general and shows
how from one second to the next
a lot of people are in a constant state
of panic trying to get things done
rushing by a living day-to-day with no
real thought for the long-term and one
day it will all just stop similar to the
movie the rush the noise the calamity of
it all will come to an end the first
true bit of peace and quiet throughout
the entire film comes due to Howard's
death and there's no more tension no
more anxiety no more worry just a
relaxing trip from this world to the
next now what's most haunting about this
final farewell with the character is
that there's a grin spread across his
face he actually dies smiling almost
seeming like he doesn't have a care in
the world which at this point he doesn't
we see Howard throughout the movie
grinning like this but the one that
sticks with me the most is earlier in
the
film when he's placed a big bet and
garnett the bookmaker at the restaurant
says it's the most ridiculous bet he's
ever heard but howard disagrees and can
be seen smiling this is Howard when he's
at his happiest taking the long shot
showing that he's right and that he can
win it all if Howard had have survived
the final few moments of the film it's
unlikely that he would have ever had
another payout like this for the rest of
his life he played big one big and went
out on top
obviously I'm guessing that the audience
didn't want the character dead and would
have wanted him to settle his bets get a
life with his kids and used the money on
his family to live basically the life
that he'd been begging for let's be
honest though none of that mattered to
Howard he was more bothered about the
chase the excitement and thrill of it
rather than the results even with the
winnings similar to Julia the two
probably would have just bet the money
again ended up in the deep with the
Sharks and I've gone through a similar
sort of thing however here Howard
doesn't have to go through that his last
moment on earth was him winning and
winning big the character went out on
top in his element and happy so when you
look at it in some ways the ending is
actually a happy one and the character
is finally at peace uncut gems was
definitely a film I had difficulty
enjoying at the time due to its frantic
editing and pacing but in hindsight I
realized that it was all intentionally
put in place to make the ending so
perfect it's a shame that Sanger got
snubbed for the Oscar nomination because
it is genuinely one of his best and most
memorable performances in years you
haven't seen the film yet then I highly
recommend that you check it out now
especially because it's on Netflix and
it gets an 8 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on uncut gems and what you took
from the ending comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up make sure you
check out our full breakdown of the new
Netflix series The Stranger which is
gonna be linked at the end we go over
everything in the film so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from his letters 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made you want to come chat
to us after the video either follow us
at definition whitey or click the
discord link in the description below
every month we give away free movies to
people who are subscribed to the channel
and this Monty can win dr. sleep and all
you have to do is comment on a video and
make sure you sub with notifications on
the more videos he comment on and the
more you have a chance of winning so
please get involved as the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
February and the cell be shipped out
from then to ever get surprised best of
luck to everyone who takes part and I'll
see you next time
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]